[Aplausos]
cómo podemos motivar a las personas de
tu empresa en 9 minutos
bueno lo primero tendríamos que saber
qué es la motivación porque todo el
mundo habla de eso vamos a buscar en
google motivación es
y el primer resultado de motivación es
un diptongo
no nos aclara mucho pero nos da pistas
porque fijaros que habla que la
motivación es un valor es emoción
sentimiento actitud tenemos que seguir
avanzando sobre el concepto de
motivación
un amigo le pregunta a otro oye cuánta
gente trabaja en tu empresa y le
responde la mitad
[Risas]
claro porque sin motivarse depende de
uno mismo porque tanta gente elige estar
de motivada
es una pregunta sencilla verdad
porque la motivación es contextual
idiosincrática temporal y específica es
decir contextual porque depende tú estás
más motivado en unos sitios que en otros
y idiosincráticas porque tú eres una
persona que tiene una historia diferente
a otra es temporal porque una vez estás
motivado por la mañana otras veces por
la tarde y otras veces nunca y es
específica porque te motiva para
desarrollar determinadas conductas
determinados objetivos y nosotros no
el jefe le dice martínez martínez
hay que venir motivado de casa
y martinelli dice yo salgo motivado pero
es que entro aquí y se me pasa
una vez que los expertos entre comillas
en recursos humanos que dicen que venís
motivados de casa deberían quedarse en
la suya esto es una cosa básica
fijaros huevos vamos a ver un caso de
como la motivación podemos manejarla de
una forma muy sencilla imaginaros que
sois enfermeras y enfermeros y
suministrar 800 medicamentos al día y
cometes un error del 0.00 1 es decir
unos 250 errores al año pero son muchos
porque pueden ser muertes enfermedades
etcétera no los que podemos hacer para
evitar que las enfermeras y enfermeros
se equivoquen bueno pues cada vez que
están administrando los medicamentos se
ponen un chaleco que dice no me hables
que estoy administrando medicamentos
ser cool
vosotros creéis que estos best estos
chalecos le gustaba ponérselo a los
enfermeros las enfermeras no porque
parecía que no hacían bien su trabajo
pero resulta amigos que los errores
bajaron un 47% en los tres o cuatro
meses quieren motivar el cambio en tu
vida el cambio en tu empresa y en tu
contexto profesional cambia cómo
organizar las cosas no fijaros en este
estudio cambiar de sitios genera cambio
así de sencillo y genera motivaciones
nuevas juntas a un equipo de vendedores
con otro equipo de vendedores que no se
conocían y que tenían experiencia y
resulta que el aumento de desempeño
perdón que el desempeño mejora aumentan
fíjate como estamos cambiando la
motivación sin aludir a palabras ni a
frases positivas ni a ningún tipo de
reflexión retórica
qué te cuesta mucho el objetivo que no
es tan motivado pues oye si ves el vaso
medio vacío
elige un vaso más pequeño pringao
y resulta que cuando te enfocas en
comportamientos más sencillos y en
objetivos más concretos más específicos
resulta que te motivas más entonces la
motivación de qué depende
yo siempre me gusta la palabra moraleja
es muy muy
muy profunda pero nos dice cosas cuando
hablamos de la motivación porque dice ni
se tiene ni se trae tú nos llevas tu
motivación la motivación es un resultado
de lo que tú haces con tu vida de los
sitios en los que trabajas de las
personas con las que te relacionas de
los incentivos que hay en las
organizaciones etcétera la motivación no
se tiene no se trae
es un resultado de tu vida bueno ya
hemos definido la motivación como una
interacción
la motivación no es un concepto no es
una competencia no es algo que llevas
dentro vamos a ver ahora que esos cuáles
son los motivadores qué es lo que nos
motiva como profesionales vamos a ver lo
que busca la gente como tú y como yo con
dice quiero un trabajo como pensáis que
la gente
busca trabajo pues como lo va a buscar
estables
dignos tranquilos desde casa de lunes a
viernes que me haga feliz donde viaje
mucho
eso lo que la gente esto lo que nos
motiva no
entonces en este contexto de la gente
tiene esa motivación es la pasta eso es
tan importante
fijaros voy a resumir para los que no
soy avezado en psicología de recurso
humano la pirámide de maslow en tres
segundos si ya es comido y ya es cobrado
lo que quiere ahora es que te presten
atención
esto equivale a un máster de recursos
humanos en muchas universidades de
muchos tipos
pero como psicólogo tengo que venir con
esa vena academicista y los psicólogos
además que hay dos super motivadores que
son los motivadores inagotables de los
que no nos cansamos que son el dinero y
la atención social nunca nos cansamos
nos cansamos del sexo bueno una vez
conocí a una persona que no y nos
cansamos de la comida
pero estamos dispuesto a recibir tanto
dinero y tanta atención social como sea
posible
entonces fijaros es que el dinero cuando
me dicen es que el dinero no es
importante para la motivación incluso el
que gana ya mucho dinero para el que
gana mucho más que tú más dinero
significa mayor reconocimiento y mayor
estatus nadie se cansa del dinero otra
cosa es que tenga otras motivaciones
estas reflexiones si nos pagan más lo
haremos mejor
tengo malas noticias
en este estudio el dinero puede
incrementar el esfuerzo pero no la
inteligencia
suele ocurrir al revés el talento
aumenta la motivación pero la motivación
generalmente no aumenta el talento ya
hemos definido la motivación hemos visto
algunos motivadores importantísimos como
aplicamos eso para que el clima de la
empresa y la colaboración sean los que
nosotros queremos sean prósperos
el jefe le vuelve a decir a martínez o
la jefa cómo es que no está usted
trabajando martínez y martínez porque
dice es que no le vi llegar al jefe
claro en una cultura del presentismo que
parece que cobras por estar en esa
cultura por la gente se acostumbra no la
cultura de una empresa que por lo que
hacen los trabajadores lo que hace lo
que hacen los profesionales cuando los
directivos no están o cuando nadie los
supervisa no
tú querías trabaja en este ambiente
o querría trabajar en este otro
fijaros en eeuu que siempre vamos unos
días 15 años por detrás respecto a la
precarización del mercado de trabajo es
decir empleados que trabajan en eeuu
cuantos crees que están comprometidos
eso que se llama en inglés engagement
y en córdoba buen rollo
cuanto están comprometidos
32%
y cuantos no están comprometidos hay
sorpresa
el 51%
y los que faltan los que faltan no es
que no estén comprometidos y que están
activamente comprometidos
entonces claro gente como esa le dicen
sonríe y se positivo
ya lo estoy intentando te lo juro
claro esta gente a esa gente pues se
llama 90 personas tóxicas y os habéis
dado cuenta de que era todo es tóxico el
otro día en el metro de madrid escuché a
una adolescente 17 años
16 años que le decía a su amiga tía mi
novio es tóxico
claro y hay libros sobre la toxicidad
cabello me pregunto hay alguna persona
tóxica en esta sala
porque yo pregunto siempre y nunca
encuentro a nadie quiero entrevistarlo
sabes porque no hay ninguna persona
tóxica en la sala
vamos a averiguarlo alguna vez te has
levantado así
es más alguna vez también te has
acostado así
claro entonces si tú has sufrido
esta situación que decíamos que la
motivación es contextual
claro tú dices tú eres tóxico seré
tóxico
os voy a dar una buena noticia y una
mala noticia
todos somos
todos podemos ser tóxicos entre comillas
pero no somos las personas tóxicas
nuestros comportamientos lo son nuestros
contextos de trabajo lo son nuestras
relaciones lo pueden ser pero las
personas nunca podemos ser tóxica el
mayor insulto que hay ahora mismo en las
empresas y el mayor acoso es llamarle
tóxico a alguien
porque eso no te lo quitas encima esa
etiqueta todos podemos comportarnos de
forma tóxica en función de la motivación
de los contextos de los objetivos las
personas que es feliz en una empresa con
su mesa su ventana y su plantita la
cambian al shots al sótano se vuelve
tóxico
lo tóxico es el sótano
pues se habla tanto de inteligencia
emocional entre comillas es una palabra
muy usada tanto como motivación talento
es lo que haces con lo que sabes pero
también lo que haces con lo que sientes
la inteligencia emocional no es
gestionar las emociones las emociones no
se pueden gestionar lo que se puede
gestionar en la vida para tener mejores
emociones la autoestima no se puede
levantar levante la autoestima a dónde
lo que puedes mejorar tu vida para
sentirte más poderoso y más feliz no así
que tenemos que conseguir esto en los
contextos laborales un profesional es
alguien que necesita a otro profesional
esa es la única reflexión que tenemos
que hacer cuando estamos hablando de la
cultura moraleja
oye pues sé tú mismo a menos que sea
mejor que no
[Aplausos]
claudia y mi felicidad para cuando
como habla mucho de motivación para
cuando mi felicidad
y yo que soy ya digo muy académico muy
de mirar estudios muy de revisar e
investigaciones yo encontrado tres cosas
que hacen que las personas seamos
felices aunque yo prefiero la palabra
próspero no uno que no haya miedo en la
empresa que no haya miedo en la empresa
ni en la pareja ni en otros sitios no
desarrollo profesional y relaciones
personales eso las tres cosas que no
sean felices
yo preguntaría yo sé feliz quiero está
en mi zona de confort que ahora parece
que todos tenemos que salir de la zona
de confort ya mí cuando me dice alguien
sal de la zona de confort yo os digo
salto piltrafilla
esta es su zona de confort o no
qué pensáis yo creo que sí está en su
zona de confort sabéis por qué porque la
zona de confort
no es el sitio donde estás cómodo es el
éxito dónde están motivados y las
personas solo salen de la zona de
confort por dos razones porque le eche
aunque luego pongo en el currículum dejé
una vida maravillosa por emprender mi
empresa
te hecharon con yo te echaron
o dejan una zona de confort porque
porque encuentran otras zonas de confort
porque ya no están tan confortables
aunque la gente desde fuera piense que
eso era un sitio que estaban a gusto
moraleja no salga de tu zona de confort
a la más grande
podemos añadir
podemos añadir para darle más fuerza a
la frase no salga de tu zona de confort
a la más grande piltrafilla
es un directivo un directivo no tiene
que decirle a un compañero a nadie que
salga de ningún sitio lo que tiene que
es ayudarle a que esté más a gusto que
esté más motivado y que sea más
profesional
como podemos diferenciar el ánimo de la
motivación y así cerramos cuando
hablamos del concepto motivación porque
todo el mundo dice te veo poco motivado
se ve hoy poco animado verdad es
complicado tienen mala actitud de la
actitud hablaremos otro día
como diferenciarlos os voy a pedir que
nos pongamos de pie 30 segundos por
favor dejar las cosas con cariño
y vamos a diferenciar entre el ánimo y
la motivación de una forma muy sencilla
pensad que estáis muy tristes brazos
abajo postura corporal un poco caída
taiz triste de hecho me estoy poniendo
más triste yo de veros
y vamos a mejorar nuestro ánimo muy
sencillo tenemos que saltar a mi ritmo
muy despacito muy despacito 12 a mi
ritmo 3 4 5 6 7 palmas
9 10 11 vueltecita vueltecita vueltecita
vueltecita vueltecita vueltecita muchas
gracias muchas gracias
motivar no es dar ánimos
las emociones fluctúan
es muy fácil animarnos pero es muy
difícil motivarnos porque necesitamos un
contexto
un objetivo unos motivos el ánimo se
puede gestionar con el deporte con el
ejercicio con la actividad pero la
motivación requiere una planificación y
mucho cariño muchas gracias a todos